everyone's favorite adolescent kung fu
fighting turtles will return this summer
and in their sequel to their 2014
adventure it looks like they're bringing
some of their cartoon companions with
them I'm Simon and this is your
entertainment news update Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles out of the shadows hits
theaters on June 3rd but you can see
Casey Jones fighting evil ninjas with a
hockey stick right now Paramount
Pictures Australia posted a video to
YouTube which features Jones using his
hockey stick in some interesting ways he
shoots pucks at the bodies blocks
incoming attacks and hits them in the
groin this alone is worth the 10 minute
misconduct and a fine in the NHL
Jones is played by arrow star Stephen
Amell who also appeared in the flash and
legends of tomorrow Amell is joined in
out of the shadows by co-stars Megan Fox
Will Arnett and Tyler Perry the turtles
are played by Pete Kozik as Leonardo
Alan Ritchson as Raphael Jeremy Howard
as Donatello and Noll Fischer as
Michelangelo out of the shadows
introduces several classic villains
including bebop who's played by Gary
Anthony Williams Rocksteady who's played
by WWE Superstar Sheamus and Krang who's
played by comedian Fred Armisen did you
like the last Michael Bay produced
reimagining of your childhood or do you
think these films are just CGI sacrilege
let me know in the comments or come find
me on Twitter I'm at the jaqen or thanks
for watching and for your entertainment
news keep it GameSpot